i got a rather good comment not too long
ago just on my last video that made me
think about a few things and i just want
to share some thoughts with you about
programming and
about getting stuff done when
programming in general and uh this is
sort of one of my processes and it's a
little unconventional and just to go a
little further back on that i tend to be
a little unconventional as you may or
may not have noticed i don't tend to
follow all the rules although i'd like
to know the rules so i know when i can
essentially break them or when i must
follow them and that sort of thing but
oftentimes if you try to follow every
single rule what ends up happening is
you just get stuck because
you come across a roadblock and it's not
like a real roadblock it's just like oh
well you could just get it done but
you're not allowed to
so what do you do you just sit there
stuck forever or do you just get it done
anyway and most the time for me as long
as it's not hurting anyone i tend to
just go for the get it done type of
method and that's true for about
everything i do i try not to spend an
exorbitant amount of time on any one
particular thing although it does tend
to happen so let me let me just dive in
and show you an example
so my last video i was just showing some
tests and showing some things
on on this program i'm writing and
one of the things i'm doing that's
rather unconventional with these tests
is up at the top of my test i have all
these globals they're essentially just a
reused stuff
constants for model paths that are being
reloaded over and over and normally this
is bad practice and someone pointed that
out and they're not wrong it is bad
practice but
the thing is
i'm trying to test a different scenario
than most tests test as this is a game
engine one of the things that i was
having trouble with getting correct in
this whole entire engine as it's getting
more complicated all the time and bigger
all the time and changing frequently is
i was having a little trouble managing
every little thing sometimes when i
unload things i'll forget to unload some
certain thing or maybe i
shared access to some object somewhere
and forgot about it because there's a
lot of things that need to talk to each
other and it's not always super easy to
keep track of and one of the ways i
started tracking that was i just
basically
made sure all these values were properly
reset and you can't necessarily
necessarily do that between tests if you
well if you destroy all the stuff and
completely close everything sure it
shuts down you don't actually
leak memory like if you have a memory
leak case for example where your program
would normally leak memory here and you
just close the program
it does release the memory but
you still have the memory leak that you
should fix but you won't notice it if
you just close the program so the point
here is i don't just close the program i
leave it running as it's right here it's
a global instead uh think of like a
playstation or an xbox or something
sometimes you just do you hit the reset
button right you don't you don't fully
power it off and cut the power and then
you know power back on instead you just
call a reset on all its core values and
have it reinitialize everything so i
wanted to shut down the sound devices i
want to shut down the graphics stuff i
want to shut down anything else like
that that is uh
needed initialized to get up and running
and uh this gets tricky with static
variables too the static variables don't
shut down on their own they stay in
scope forever essentially once they're
initialized they don't reinitialize so
you have to manually de-initialize them
so you gotta be really careful about
static values and there's some of those
in this engine to try to make things
more efficient for example when you load
a model
the importer is generally static so that
if you load like 10 models in a row it
doesn't keep recreating the importer it
just makes it once and it's more
efficient that way basically i'm
breaking some
c plus standards guidelines
quite frequently and the reason i'm
doing that is to actually be able to get
stuff done like if i start doing
something then i have the thought that
uh does this follow the core guidelines
i could go research the guidelines all
day or i could use the knowledge i have
about c plus plus and about how things
work and just make cases that seem to
work for this scenario so the whole
point of this is it's like the old
saying you gotta you gotta crack a few
eggs to make an omelet so i'm not saying
that you shouldn't follow rules and
convention i think in general you should
but
if you're trying to be productive you're
always going to come up with scenarios
are always going to run into scenarios
where the roadblock is not
a physical thing the roadblock is not
actually there it's just simply like
this mental block of oh but there's a
rule that says i can't do that and of
course those rules have good reasons you
know like when you're driving and you
come to a stoplight if it's red you stop
if you're in a rush though maybe it's a
life and death situation and you can see
very clearly that there's no cars and
there's a zero percent chance of any
accident uh you can say look maybe it's
more important that i get this person
i'm rushing to the hospital to the
hospital then i sit here at a road with
no with zero traffic at a stop light the
point is
you know you can see it clearly you can
use your own judgment and you don't
necessarily need to follow the rules and
i think some people might just need to
hear this sort of thing
it is urgent it's kind of even hard to
say like it's a fact of life that our
time here is limited the stuff you get
done is kind of urgent you either get it
done or you don't there's there's no you
don't get like bonus time you don't get
extra days at the at the end of the end
of the road it's just over man
so as uh as hard as that is to say in
here
it is the truth
and uh here i am breaking yet another
convention by telling you that because
that's not something people just tell
you uh generally but that's the reality
of things so that's a thing that you
just need to
sometimes you just need to get things
done
and uh not really worry about what
everybody's gonna say and all that stuff
anyway i hope you got something out of
this video if you did consider hitting
the like button and uh follow we'll be
updating this i'm going to do another
vlog on this engine there's been a lot
of changes uh i'm doing a vlog a month
pretty much
and uh yeah i've kind of kind of got a
system worked out but we'll see where it
goes a lot of plans for the future of it
but i just wanted to make this quick
one-off to
to basically just explain that uh if you
want to actually get stuff done you just
gotta do it man and you gotta not think
about every single rule and regulation
and what people are gonna think you just
gotta do it well that's it for this
video peace out guys also if you want to
see more videos in higher productions uh
consider
visiting the sponsor of this video
uh me and my patron the link will be
down below any amount helps and helps
keep this channel going and me producing
videos and content and i'll see you guys
later
[Music]
you